[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
thank you so much for listening today is
just like honestly the kind of
conversation that I love to have it's
smart it's spiritual it's psychedelic
it's extraterrestrial and it's all
brought to you by a highly accomplished
brilliant doctor Dr Trevor Berry is a
board-certified chiropractic neurologist
and he said I said how do you want to be
introduced and he said a resident
psychonaut so really just saying that we
just get into these spaces that are a
little different they're not just
classic science they're not classic
neurology
um and so uh just to explain a little
bit more he has been an international
speaker since 2010 he lectures on brain
injuries neurodegeneration nutrition and
functional medicine Laboratory Testing
neurological diagnostic testing
functional neurology and low-level laser
therapy so anyway basically he's done so
much research in the field of the brain
chain and the body and inflammation he
tells the story at the very beginning
about why he got into it which has to do
with his daughter he's come across these
lasers that are a cool laser they're a
low laser like a perfect bandwidth to be
able to use on a regular basis as well
as have no negative reaction so um I
worked with him last year to help with
what was diagnosed as post-concussional
syndrome so I did 12 sessions in the
course of four weeks so I went a couple
of times a week and just had such
incredible biomarker feedback improving
from the very beginning to the very end
but he talks tons about the lasers what
they do what creates good brain health
what helps with longevity with with not
aging and then we got into psychedelics
which he is a big proponent of and has
tested them all himself and has amazing
stories from as well as then his trip to
Egypt and Consciousness and fractals and
the universe and what is reality and I
love these conversations so I hope you
love it as much as I did please let me
know what you think in the feedback I'd
love to I'd love to hear what your
thoughts are and please hit subscribe I
really appreciate all the subscriptions
it tells me that you guys really enjoy
what's going on on the screen and please
hit the bell for notifications I I
totally thought you were going to give
me a definition of penrose's quantum
Consciousness Theory
if that was plausible because people
don't even know how to define
consciousness yet then that I might
consider it but so if you the cliff
notes is is when you look at the
microtubules
um it you know the
theory is stating that for that to have
that little mini computer inside a
neuron there has to be a fractal pattern
and so the theory is that that fractal
pattern those electrons bouncing around
are with our our stage within that
microtubule which is actually the
scaffolding of the neuron of the brain
and so that's scaffolding that by itself
is a fractal pattern like when a cell
divides that's actually a fractal
pattern that is made as that skeleton
pulls the cell and divides it into two
well can that's also the transport
system that is made between the two so
like if Neuron a is talking to neuron B
it's the microtubules that communicate
and send those growth factors in the
neurotransmitters and all that down the
tubule well that's actually where they
believe the fractal is containing that
little mini quantum computer
and of course like you know the way that
the neurons in the brain fire looks like
the fabric of the universe and how
information passes so look like I'm kind
of obsessed with fractals and quantum
entanglement uh I find that a very
fascinating topic as well
um so we're going to let that be like a
cliffhanger for people to keep listening
so uh we can talk about some how we met
and the work we did together uh and then
we can get into fractals and
microtubules and
um Consciousness and Egypt because you
went to Egypt last year and of course I
went to Egypt the year before so you
know there's a lot to a lot to
um have fun with playing in those uh you
know spaces of conversation but first
and foremost
I met you
for brain health so maybe go I think
it's actually like I loved you telling
the story about how you got into lasers
how you got into
um why you got into them and your
motivation because I think there's such
authenticity and the reason why you
became really obsessed and determined to
figure out what created the the
healthiest brain the least inflammation
in the brain and body so
um so please if you're willing to share
yeah my why definitely stems from my my
ex-wife and I have two daughters and she
has unfortunately has a severe familial
predilection for Alzheimer's
um and you know as my daughters had to
witness this in their upbringing about
those you know that that family decline
uh you know I was really worried
obviously with that genetic predilection
everything I could do to protect those
two especially after they had to witness
like their grandmother go through it
things like that they said you know
their big thing was you know the tears
in their I was like Daddy this isn't
going to happen to us is it and I I
vowed to them as long as I'm on this
planet breathing I'm going to do
everything I can in research and
clinical applications to protect those
two you know and so that's that's why
the laser thing was so important to me
because I'm I was trying to find ways
that that were efficacious you know the
literature was there and but you know
when it comes to neurodegeneration like
Alzheimer's it's such a multifactorial
thing that you have to address there's
not one Smoking Gun when it comes to
neurodegeneration there you have to
address as you alluded to brain
inflammation autoimmunity barrier
systems mitochondria and energy you know
the list just goes on and on so you
start looking at well how do I check off
those boxes and what's interesting about
low-level laser therapy is that when you
look it's almost too good to be true
because when you look at all the major
major physiological changes that you
need to protect the brain low level
laser can actually produce all of them
it can facilitate energy it can actually
even promote new nerve generation or
neurogenesis in the brain new
mitochondrial formation for energy
production and as we get more into the
microtubule thing if you look at when
the brains go down the hill you know
everyone's focusing on amyloid right now
that plaque that Gunk on the outside of
a neuron and there's some relevance to
that but the newer research shows that
actually it may even be a
neuroprotective thing there are times
when it's bad like when we have too much
sugar in our diet and our Western you
know all all the carb loading that we do
that tends to Gunk up the outside of the
neurons that's why a lot of researchers
call it Alzheimer's type 3 uh you know
type 3 diabetes is actually a term
that's sometimes used so sugar causes
that's one of the mechanisms that causes
that to Gunk up but what we want to look
at is actually what are these what are
called protein mistfuls and so that's
scaffolding of the microtubules that
communication Network that beautiful
architecture inside the cell that's held
together by these Tau proteins and when
those proteins misfold that that whole
architecture falls apart and the neuron
dies what causes those architectural to
fold so with those proteins are
misfolded uh basically what happens is
it's there's a couple models there one
is one is a toxin and inflammation model
so you can look at it from that
perspective you know you went through a
lot of autoimmune stuff last year and
you were gracious to share like your
explant stuff when you look at the
immune system when it gets ticked off
that's one thing that can be a precursor
for that another big one is
excitotoxicity when too much calcium and
too much glutamate is in going into the
neuron it can cause proteins to misfold
so this is why we don't want to do like
Diet products for example and things of
that nature what does that mean diet
like diet soda for example low calorie
stuff if you want to whack a neuron go
ahead and and drink a diet soda kind of
thing because you it's like a Goldilocks
effect you need the right amount of
calcium to come into a neuron to
activate the system but if too much
calcium comes in it actually causes this
whole Cascade free radical damage and
and all these things that cause the
proteins to to become uh you know when
you look at transcription like when the
proteins are replicating it causes that
to become faulty so that that beautiful
Golden Gate Bridge that is your
microtubules it's like being put
together with faulty cement and when it
collapses you know the neuron goes by by
well those lasers actually not only
protect that concrete to make sure those
Tau proteins are healthy it can actually
reverse damage protein so they're
actually yeah with low level laser
they're actually showing reversal of
those plaques and reversal of Tau
protein buildup so those are two big
players in the field of
neurodegeneration does that include when
you talk about like diet diet products
does that include all the other more um
the newer sweeteners Stevia and
erythrall and those kinds of sweeteners
as well I'm okay with like an organic
Stevia first fruit that's yeah long
fruit I'm good with organic honey you
know things like I'm I'm good with that
it's the artificial stuff and all the
derivatives of it and and you know even
like monosodium glutamate is another one
you hear about glutamate toxicotoxicity
so that's you know we got to watch for
things like I love when you post on your
social media that you eat good organic
healthy you know lots of good fish good
meat good vegetables that kind of stuff
that's what we need our diets to be
based around to have a healthy brain and
prevent neurodegeneration yeah a lot of
a lot of dementia is based on Western
you know Western Tendencies of what we
tend to consume here in in our society
so how does the how out of the cold
laser I want you to talk about the
lasers because I know that you know
you've searched for a long time for the
right lasers and the archonia lasers are
what the best are because they're a cool
laser versus a a hot laser but before we
explain that so people understand what
we're talking about and and why I came
in to see you in the work we did
um does that also affect the telomeres
like what role do the do telomeres have
on top of everything else that you were
just talking about because telomeres I
understand have to do with aging and
those shorten over time too
exactly that biological aging process is
definitely tied in telomere shortening
is is definitely a process that the
lasers have been shown to protect that
and and the mechanism that's been seen
is there's a uh if you look at the like
the master
antioxidant anti-aging system it's
called Nrf2 nerf2 and lasers especially
that red one that you have that's 635 5
nanometer has been shown to activate
Nrf2 and that will prevent or that will
help mitigate the aging and the damaging
process on our DNA sequences a food
analogous to that that would be the
glucoraphins or sulfurophenes that are
heavy in broccoli one of the superfoods
is broccoli for a reason that's your
highest source of group of rafinins and
sulforaphane so lasers will emulate that
process with that antioxidant free
radical anti-aging kind of protection so
that's one of the first benefits of your
laser is when you look at glutathione
superoxide dismutase catalase all those
big ones that are the mother of all
antioxidants lasers promote those
systems for you just like eating
blueberries though you know and those
kind of things so lasers do that
antioxidant I know you mentioned in in
one of your I think it was your final
podcast you love glutathione and NAC and
for good reason NAC is one of the super
nutrients we're using in long covid and
Mica mold stuff we're using a across the
board we're using NAC well lasers do all
that antioxidant stuff for you brain
inflammation is one of the biggest
things that we have to Tamp down if you
just because you have a genetic
predilection for something doesn't mean
it has to manifest we all have problems
in our Gene Snips you know in our DNA
sequence but it doesn't mean it has to
become a disease or actually manifest to
you at creating an illness well when you
look at the number one epigenetic
tripwire like what are we doing to
ourselves that actually would push you
off that Cliff if you were predisposed
like apoe4 for example it's brain
inflammation and brain inflammation it
comes from many sources obviously our
diet's one of them head trauma which
we're about to get into with traumatic
brain injury and post-concussion
syndrome
um pathogens viruses in the brain
bacteria cause it those kind of things
so our number one job is to Tamp down
inflammation and so when you look at all
the Cascades of inflammation the
linchpin being what's called nuclear
Factor Kappa beta and it just don't
worry about these terms it's just that
the inflammation it's it's your immune
system's attempt to protect you so we
need inflammation in the short term you
just don't want chronic inflammation
none of us want chronic inflammation and
so one of the problems with CTE and
post-concussion syndrome and whatnot is
that the inflammation Cascade doesn't
get turned off your brain stays ticked
off so you stay in like flight
essentially yeah fight or flight you
know you're like in fight or flight all
the time it never down regulates and the
Cascade effect of that is brain
inflammation what else so brain
inflammation will cause things like that
that will lead to changes in the in when
you look at the neurons and how they
operate it's there there's the primary
neuron right but you have all these
supporting neurons they're called your
glial cells and they make up your blood
brain barrier they make up the pruning
of the bonsai tree that is your brain
they make up the new like the the
immunes part of your brain they just
found a new layer in your skull and your
meninges by the way it's called the
Slime layer and that's where all those
immune cells hang out it could come up
with a better name than slime layer
exactly subarachnoid lymph lymph layer
so what what lasers do is they actually
promote healthy neuronal and immune
responses so you need to send out the
attack or the SWAT team right to to
fight like defend you say you're under
attack by a virus or a bacteria but you
have to turn that off and I use the
analogy when I lecture when I teach it's
like you're those glial cells like your
microglia are like the Bruce Banner of
your brain they're these super sharp
scientists by day but if you punch Bruce
Banner in the head he turns into the
Hulk right and Hulk smash now Hulk's
protecting you but you also see what
he's doing to the city the cars the
streets like it's it's tumbling down
well that cortical atrophy that that
those buildings coming down that in
essence is the same thing that's
happening in Alzheimer's and in CTE or
post like chronic post-concussion cases
you start to see cortical atrophy so
what we have to do is find ways for the
Hulk to turn back into Bruce Banner and
they literally just came up with a study
last week that shows those glial cells
or last month sorry that they
shape-shipped they actually yeah I kind
of use it as a funny analogy but it
turns out those glial cells shape-shift
like the The Hulk does to protect you
and so they and Laser Studies have been
shown to turn the Hulk back into that
super sharp scientist Bruce Banner to go
back to all the other important tasks
that it does so lasers will do that um
some nutrients to do that are like
omega-3 fatty acids fish oil is really
good to turn you know those those
pro-resolving meters turmeric is a big
one that does that as well too and again
your glutathione and n-acetyl cysteine
there we go again so those are just some
ways to Tamp down inflammation and get
the Hulk to calm down I mentioned in
that sentence the blood brain barrier
our barrier systems you know that's you
have like single cell layers in your gut
and then in your brain you have just
these astrocytes protecting you from the
outside world and so if you get
disruption in blood brain bearing gut
barrier here then you have to repair it
you got to put it back together
otherwise bad stuff gets in like metals
like viruses those kind of things well
Studies have been shown that lasers will
protect not only your gut barrier repair
your gut barrier but also your blood
brain barrier so that's another layer of
protection that's big in the grand scale
of things so how does because one of the
things that I did and we're totally
going to get to these lasers eventually
and what exactly they are but the one of
the things that I did and part of my
protocol because uh for people that
listen to me a lot would know that I had
heavy metal toxicity
um turns out I have mold to some degree
too if two different strains but the one
in particular was for heavy metals and
especially Mercury Mercury gets into the
brain and crosses the blood-brain
barrier so one of my Moda one of my
supplements that I was using was a
certain tincture that I and just put in
my mouth that crossed the blood-brain
barrier to detox so how does if like how
does it get in are there just certain
substances that cross the blood-brain
barrier no matter how strong it is yeah
there's that element usually there are
certain things that will punch their own
hole like a trojan horse through the
blood-brain barrier and so yes certain
Metals will actually create their own
disruption in the barrier systems free
radicals um and and you know Advanced
glycogen products like homocysteine when
we don't have proper B vitamins and
things like that will do gluten can
actually do it like wheat German
glutenants things like that can actually
punch tickets like here's a good example
some of the the research that goes into
brain cancers one of the ways they were
trying to get the Cancer drugs into the
brain was using the gluten to actually
punch a hole in there to get it in there
it's not the primary method but it just
kind of you know illustrates you know
how that can do it so yeah but even in
um a traumatic brain injury we're seeing
within four to six hours of every TBI
that you're developing leaky brain and
leaky gut as a matter sorry what's that
leaky brain and every with every TBI I'm
sorry traumatic dramatic brain injury so
when you have a traumatic brain like so
say uh you know unfortunately say we
have a crash in a car or something right
yeah so right away not you didn't ever
have any of those but when they do
happen it is something that you the
barriers open up and one of the markers
that we use is called g-fat but that
means that the proteins of the brain got
into the bloodstream and they shouldn't
be in there your brain should be like a
king and queen on a castle behind the
boat behind you know the castle wall
that kind of thing so if you're seeing
proteins out in the bloodstream from the
brain that's not a good sign so that if
stuff can go out that means stuff is
going in like mold like uh like heavy
metals and that kind of stuff so then
you have to draw those out like you were
talking about we use fulvic acid humic
acid there's different things can draw
that stuff out right to get it out of
there which is some of the stuff you did
and then lasers come in and Tamp out
that inflammation that it created and
seal that barrier to protect it again
yeah okay talk about the lasers and what
makes arconia lasers different than the
other ones that you have researched yeah
so that that you know when when you
start putting all these pieces together
it's not like is this too good to be
true it checks off like 50 boxes that
you need for your brain there is the
catch though the one the main caveat
that you see in research is that there's
a Goldilocks effect of dose and energy
and weight and wavelength activity and
what that means is is light sources have
certain power it has certain wavelength
that kind of stuff and what all the
literature shows is that you don't want
to exceed 10 joules per centimeter
squared to the brain I know that's going
to sound Greek to most people but it's
just you don't need you know less is
more when it comes to laser there's
paper after paper in Immunology in brain
in cancer studies with laser not
exceeding that threshold if you can stay
below that then away you go and that's
your safe Zone to stay in so this laser
right here here is perfectly situated to
stay in the low end of the dose response
that's safe to use on the brain a good
example on the other the far end of the
power spectrum is that you know surgical
lasers that are super high powered
they're designed to zap tissue like a
blade tissue and that kind of stuff
obviously we're not trying to do that to
the brain therapeutically so the low
level laser that's below 10 joules per
centimeter squared or what's called 10
electron volts that is your perfect
sweet spot so airconia does that so my
first job as a physician especially on
my daughter's head is to do no harm so
that's why I'm not going to do a high
power device on anyone's head those
devices when you look at infrared and
near infrared like we a lot of us will
do infrared saunas and stuff right those
are longer wavelengths that heat up
water molecules to cook it that's what a
microwave is well I'm not going to stick
my head in a microwave and I so I
definitely don't want to you know do any
high powered stuff on that far end of
the spectrum the other end of the
spectrum is Led so what that is is
you'll see these like inexpensive
devices that are on Amazon and stuff
like laser they call them laser pointers
they're not laser those are just
scattered photons of energy and so what
we like that's they're they're a lot
less expensive because it takes a lot of
money in engineering to get all those
photons of energy working together in
the exact same direction collimated all
working together to get better outcomes
so just to give you an example on the
LED end of the spectrum we use it as our
sham Placebo when we do laser studies so
we'll compare ariconia to an LED because
we do double blind studies on all these
devices as a matter of fact further to
that airconia when you look at FDA
clearances draconia has 20 of the 24 FDA
clearances they have more FDA coverage
than any all the laser companies
combined so and we've never had a side
effect reported in any of the FDA
studies you show me anything yeah any
study that has that so so you want to be
somewhere in between high powered and
led well the true laser that it's right
in between is ericonian they nailed it
and that's why I attached my cart to
their horse mmm
well that makes sense
um does that mean that you can use it
every day kind of thing too is that when
it's not uh when it has no negative
effect on the brain because of the
bandwidth that it's using does that also
mean that you can use it all the time is
there an overdose that you can go have
of the laser it in theory it could be
but you'd have to do lasers for 14 hours
with the arconia to exceed dose so
you're pretty safe on that front most
people aren't going to do a 14-hour
treatment
um you know so I would look at it from
in short yes you can I do I do it every
day my whole office staff is under
lasers every day at lunch it's kind of
funny when you see us like this is my uh
my fx405 right behind me here one of the
ways you can actually regrow neurons in
your brain is lasering it
and so what I do there's also you may
have read the studies with uh meditation
meditation actually promotes new
neuronal Pathways especially in the
hippocampus that memory Center yeah yeah
so if you want to do a one-two punch to
really help with your hippocampus and
gray matter
while doing it exactly it's a beautiful
thing so I do it all the time now I used
to not even be able to meditate on my
brain I was working way on high beta too
much stuff so it was actually Ayahuasca
that actually taught me how to do
meditation stuff oh my God we'll get
into that later hopefully totally yeah
so so but meditation is really good you
know sitting under the laser while you
do memory recall stuff is good sitting
under the laser doing happy thoughts for
depression like default mode Network
work is phenomenal for that they've done
lots of laser studies on depression so
is it just perpetuating is it just a
momentum like because you know you and I
can get really into the woo-woo space of
energy and quantum physics and all of
that stuff but but based on what you're
saying in the studies does that mean is
this does it
um uh
heighten or exacerbate momentum
essentially yeah so when you look at all
the the when when neurons are trying to
connect and make new Pathways and stuff
the main thing they need is energy and
it goes back to that mitochondria thing
I know you had Dave asprey who's like
the mitochondria Guru right like
bulletproof all that stuff I love that
mitochondria is the PowerHouse it
actually has its own DNA so it's not
just your nuclear DNA mitochondria has
its own DNA you know where we get that
DNA from our moms our mothers pass on my
we're the you guys are the PowerHouse
right well moms are the PowerHouse
they're the ones that that create the
energy for that and what we've just
found in recent studies is that each
different color of wavelength actually
protects different parts of the
mitochondria so that's why like you have
red which is the rate limiting enzyme
and violet which protects the first two
complexes and then this is that new one
this is the green Violet one and we just
found out green is the one that actually
protects the third complex so now we've
got the whole mitochondria cover so now
you have these these great energy
producing things so that your brain can
work all of its magic make new
connections make you know memories make
all these things and grow Pathways but
then you want to activate the brain at
the same time or sometimes thereafter so
that's like you get a lot of your
therapies we would not only do laser
passively as an anti-inflammatory anti
uh you know free radical all these good
things that it does but we would even
like while you were doing some of those
complex brain exercises that we did with
you we would laser your brain at the
same time and so that just promote the
momentum of improving those uh those
um that those patterns or those
um those uh you know uh systems in my
brain that are trying to be able to pick
the dots up quicker to be able to track
more accurately with my eyes and gaze
stabilize so we were promoting more of
what I was trying to do that makes that
that that that's fantastic exactly um
that okay so what what did I so I came
in and we did a baseline evaluation and
what the hell did you find
well so one of the things doctors got to
get back to doing is being doctors like
we become just oh you got this let's run
this test and see what comes back or
here let's give you this prescription
and see if that that mitigates those
symptoms but when it comes to neurology
you have to take an integrative approach
right you have to understand hormones
and thyroid function and adrenal
function and all these things that
affect the brain the heart so we did a
full cardiac work up on you like heart
rate variability testing and bilateral
blood pressure and all that and then we
assess the entire brain you remember how
long I you know I spent on average
between 45 minutes and an hour just
doing my my initial bedside neural
workout because I'm looking at the
different parts the frontal lobe the
parietal lobe the visual system the
auditory system the cerebellum so we we
assess all that and then when I put it
all together and paint that whole
picture of what your body's doing my job
as an integrative neurologist is to take
those weak links in your in your system
and do stuff to stimulate them now
whether I stimulate it with direct laser
application like like your left
cerebellum for example or if I um do it
with nutrients or some sort of other
thyroid support you know whatever it
takes you have to be able to have a
multimodal approach because I'll line up
10 Alzheimer's patients and all of 10
different treatment plans yeah there are
certain common denominators but there's
individual underpinnings to each you
know some of my Alzheimer's patients is
because of virus some of them it's
because of an anemia pattern like they
don't have iron or B vitamins or
whatever you know or some combination of
all the above so what we did was we
assessed your entire nervous system to
see where those weaknesses were and then
we prescribe certain exercises and Laser
protocols and stuff to activate those
areas because if you've got a weak bicep
what do you do to make it stronger you
do bicep curls right right well yeah if
I've got a weak right cerebellum you
know the little brain there that
coordinates all your muscle activity you
know what are you going to do to make
that stronger if I have a weak left
frontal lobe so we prescribe exercises
to Target and activate those weak areas
of the brain
okay and that's what I have yeah what
did I have what what was the what was my
what was my um condition
and then like what was it that we broke
it down into to fix it well you did have
some of the Hulk smash stuff going on
and one of the other things that we do
with that is uh to Tamp down
inflammation and protect the barriers is
we did a lot of vagal nerve stimulation
with you explain that explain the vagal
nerve because I don't maybe a lot of
people don't understand it and you know
maybe I don't completely understand it
so go ahead yeah so you've got
um when you hear about the brain gut
axis yeah we're a there's a pretty
important communication that goes from
your brain to your digestive system and
your gut microbiome like all the good
bugs in your in your gut hopefully
they're good not bad ones and those good
bacteria and what your gut's doing has a
direct highway to the brain it's called
the vagus nerve and so there's an output
of the vagus nerve but there's even more
input that goes from the gut to the
brain and then you even have the
polyvagal theory which you've probably
read about like love and connection and
like I won't go too deep down that
rabbit hole but like when you have
intuition for example but you know
that's tied into the polyvagal theory
and the vagus nerve and so what we did
was directly activate that to help
inflammation to help that brain gut
communication and and help the barrier
systems with you and then you did have
some frontal lobe slowing you know so uh
some of your working memory like one of
the things you would talk to me about
was when you were interviewing people
and whatnot you would have a thought and
you wanted to say come back to that but
as they were talking you know it's like
okay maybe I've lost a little bit of
that so we did some stuff with that
connection between the amygdala and your
temporal lobe and the connection to the
frontal lobe and so that that Highway
that communication Highway we did
exercises to stimulate that pathway the
frontal lobe is really heavily driven by
things like Fast eye movements for
example and fast motor Factory Motor
activity so we did things like that NSI
device you would mention where we're
doing rapid you know biofeedback while
we're lasing your cerebellum which
pre-programmed so one of the cool things
about the cerebellum is that it we're
finding more and more it's like it has
over half the neurons of your entire
nervous system or in your cerebellum
that fires even before your frontal lobe
does in a lot of ways so when the
cerebellum people will you know have
things like balance issues coordination
issues but when they're having trouble
finding words and those kind of things
that's also tied into the cerebellum the
frontal lobe is tied into emotion and
inhibition and things like that so you
know it's the reason why you know when
somebody one of your buddies has too
many beers and he's naked on the table
with a lampshade on that's frontal
insert Beller inhibition they they lose
those inhibitory systems so they start
thinking yeah this is a good idea hold
my beer kind of thing so so we want to
do stuff to make those inhibitory
systems stronger and so that that you
know your whole brain is a gas break and
now you have to have a ghost system but
you have to have a stop system so we
also did some stuff with you like
anti-seconds and dual tasking and
whatnot and what those are is that if
anyone's played the game Simon says go
Simon says stop go well that's for you
know our tendency is to want to go right
and to you know you have to have that
inhibitory system and say oh Simon
didn't say and so we use that like we do
a lot with neurodevelopmental stuff with
like autistic kids and things like that
so those are just examples of those
inhibitory systems of the brain that
even though there's not as many neurons
for it they actually have more energy in
their own system and those kind of
things that's why a lot of people have
anxiety and oce because they don't get
it turned off it doesn't shut down yeah
so we'll do exercises like anti-seconds
and go no-go like Simon says stuff and
things like that to activate those
Pathways to get that those Pathways
stronger because anything you do
repetitively in the brain like learning
a new golf swing that will ultimately
start to create new Pathways and then
over time when you've reinforced it
enough that's your new normal that's the
beauty about brain plasticity as long as
you're living and breathing you can you
can be 85 years old and get your brain
function working better so it's a
beautiful thing that we have going for
us on that front you could always rehab
the brain we also worked with gaze
stabilization too what part does gaze
stabilization have
um on how someone feels and what would
reduce somebody's ability to have that
gay stabilization and
um and then and then I found it totally
fascinating to understand just how sort
of exhausting that probably was to my
system because my eyes didn't stay
focused gotcha yeah that's a great
question because the gays holding
centers in your brain stem it happens to
be right by where the vagus nerve is
actually they're right next to each
other and it's probably correlated or
are they just exactly for sure they're
correlated well technically the whole
nervous system even though we try and
compartmentalize it there's a lot of
interconnectivity so I don't want to be
you know like left brain right but at
the end of the day they're like brother
and sister right next to each other
because gay centers are your part of
your balance Center okay the main part
of gaze holding is your balance center
it's the fastest reflux in the human
body it's faster than Vision so our
ability to look at Target and move our
eyes our head around I'm sorry move our
head around that Target fastest reflux
of the human body one of the things we
see a lot in concussions and we're not
is because that's in the brain stem well
if your head's getting rattled around as
you're you'll say you're in your Nascar
or your cart Open Wheel and you take a
head or even just the you know normal
driving spirit that where's the brain
it's floating around in that fluid but
what's it floating on your brain stem so
that poor area of the brain is getting a
lot of trauma and a lot of shearing and
things like that so one of the
mechanisms is actual direct mechanical
damage to that area well that's our eyes
are basically if I took your brain and
just squeezed it out of your skull and
it popped out that's your eyes okay you
can basically with eye movements and eye
analysis see a lot no pun intended you
can analyze a lot of what's going on in
the brain based on eye movements and
Optics and ocular motor stuff so one of
the first things we look at in things
like post-concussion is can the eyes
lock on a Target didn't stay on that
Target and if they can't we that's one
of our first orders of business is to do
gaze holding exercises uh or what are
called vestibular ocular therapies to
get the eye stable so that your balance
is better your awareness of where you
are in space your reaction time is
better you don't fall that's a big thing
what do you think tell you in yoga if
you're doing a balance pose like tree
and you're all over the place that your
yoga instructor will tell you to lock
and fixate on a Target exactly you're
drishy yes exactly so that's your gaze
holding centers so one of our first
building blocks like when we build your
nervous system back up you have to be
able to have those eyes locked in place
so we worked a lot with you to develop
that foundation so that everything else
we did above it was coming from a good
foundation like that
um yeah I I just I remember when we did
that and you said that
um you know the what is the normal
amount of eye movements in a day
something 102
000 you know estimates are around 100 to
20 120 000 anything and you were
probably doing about four or five
hundred thousand eye movements a day
because of all of your extraneous
activity and re you know Corrections and
stuff yeah just your eyes are skeletal
muscle if I'm at the gym and I had you
do three sets of ten with bicep curls
you're like I can't do anymore I got
lactic acid I'm tired and I say you know
what do five more of the five more sets
of those what do you think your muscles
gonna do right what do you think your
body is going to do that's anaerobic
respiration it's you know you're
building up you know talk you know free
radicals it's exhausting you're using up
energy unnecessarily so we want the
nervous system to be efficient and by
getting all those extraneous eye
movements out of your equation your
system is going to have a lot more
energy to work with to do all the fun
stuff you like to do so yeah yeah well I
mean for those who are listening and
they're like I don't know maybe I have
gay stabilization issues or I wonder if
I do I mean I could once you pointed it
out I was like oh my God I absolutely
know the times when my eyes it's
basically like when you track or when
you track across and like they jiggle
like and I had that all the time where I
would some and I'd look and all of a
sudden I just like it would all jiggle
and I'd have to like it wasn't like I
lost my place but I was like I just had
a moment so if somebody kind of notices
that there's like a like a like a
readjusting every now and again whether
it's close or far and you're just kind
of like eyes are readjusting for me
that's that was like oh yeah I can
totally tell that that's not working
properly
um so okay so what's kind of the general
like if we work down top down from a a
Cascade effect of like how important
things are let's talk about like
um let's talk about uh stress diet
um lifestyle
um emotions
um toxins like how is there a way to
organize it in a hierarchy or is it are
they all sort of in their own Silo
affecting the system to a similar degree
I love that question because they do
have their all their own damning
qualities about it but I if I were to
try and put a hierarchy on it I would
say one thing stress is the underpinning
for a lot of our problems and it whacks
those areas of the brain like the
hippocampus your memory Center one of
the worst ways you can whack that is
stress so we have to get stress out of
our system we have to get you know into
whether it's our relationships our
careers whatever you know Finding ways
to go ground
yeah exactly
um so yeah for sure that's a big one the
next one I would say is move you have to
move you know they've they've done
studies and I just put a new one up in
my slide that they just came out with a
study where they compare diet and
exercise together they compared that in
relation to exercise alone diet and
lifestyle like the nutrition stuff alone
and then none of the above and what they
showed is that if you exercise you could
over overcome the dietary stuff with the
negative qualities of diet now I don't
want to just give people the green light
to go eat yeah but it's just it's just a
hierarchy yeah so get out and move we
become way too sedentary I don't care
what kind of movement is there is there
a certain recommended do you need to
work at like do you need to have
interval style training is it a time
under tension with muscles with lifting
weights is it just purely walking like
what would you recommend at the end of
the day I'm like I'm okay with just
getting out and walking because if
somebody's just sitting at their desk
all day and they get out and walk that's
going to be a game changer but you
brought up an excellent point high
intensity interval training is arguably
the best way to get new nerve growth
factors and insulin resistance under
control and things like that so if we
and the good thing about hit training is
like they just did a study that showed
five minutes of that or six minutes
technically could help prevent
Alzheimer's so when patients tell me I
don't have time to work out if you can't
give me three minutes of your day you
know then what are you supposed to do do
as a doctor as a patient you know you
give me three minutes of high intensity
interval training and that's going to
make huge changes in your brain and your
chemistry and your neuronal health so
what we do with high intensity interval
training is one minute on one minute off
one minute on and we do that times three
minutes that it could be jump rope it
can be elliptical trainer whatever it
whatever it is you're doing just do it
in in training in intervals even if
you're going for a walk change go really
brisk for a while and then slow it down
and change it up that way complex
movement patterns big like yoga Tai Chi
there you go so new things novelty is
big for the brain learning yeah a new
golf swing or learning how to you know
play tennis or whatever anything that
learn how to play the piano like
anything that stimulates the brain is
helps with that neuroplasticity correct
exactly exactly no new neural Pathways
now you brought us some really big
points though like toxins and viruses
and stuff those things will just you
know you have to be able to address
those and get them under control and or
get them out of the body so we look at
you know heavy metal readings like hair
analysis and different things like that
urine analysis we viruses are like you
talk about a major underpinning this is
why a lot of long coveted people are
showing dementia stuff is that now that
it's going along we're seeing some of
the effects of that so we need to do
stuff to to address the immunology and
that's why lasers are so good because
they can actually go after a lot of the
stuff that the pathogens like viruses
are doing to the brain in a bad way the
inflammation the over immune response
like the over inflammation that you know
you hear about the the coveted storm and
all that stuff but so yeah we have if
you if you have a chronic mold exposure
or something good luck having a healthy
brain but in I can say the exact same
thing in a even worse like an iron
deficiency if you're anemic you're never
going to have you know it's almost
impossible to have a healthy body if
iron is involved in every enzyme react
reaction in the human body so we had to
also do low-hanging fruit stuff like a
CBC get labs done on yourself you know
eat good foods that have good iron
sources like good red meat this is a big
misconception is that people like oh
meat's bad yeah West you know when you
have industrialized beef not good and
it's not the meat that's the problem
it's what they put into it the
antibiotics you know the the grains that
are non-GMO you know that kind of stuff
yeah and let's just look at it from a
metaphysical standpoint that that cow is
not happy that cow is being put in a
line you know like look I get it I eat
meat but you know there's there's more
Humane ways than the factory farming so
there's there's what they put into it
and and how that how that feels because
if our body is affected by how we feel
their body is affected by how they feel
exactly and you bring up a really
interesting you know when you look at
that Collective Consciousness and that
you know non-linearity of time and
whatnot there's so many layers to that
that you just opened up
and there's a lot of misinformation too
you know depending on what source you
read you've always got biases right
you've got you know and that we that we
should address because it's like yeah I
understand environmental concerns I'm a
Canadian tree hugger by Nature right so
I I want to pretend but you know here we
are cutting down the Amazon the lungs of
the Earth for the sake of feeding the
cows with or getting the soybeans and
things like that so like we want to do
stuff to protect our environment and I'm
not trying to say that into like a
politically divisive way it's just why
would we cut out the lungs like if I
started taking your long and just
methodically cutting it out like we're
doing in the Amazon eventually it's
going to catch up to you in your lung
field it's no different they are you can
lose a chunkier lungs but once you lose
it all obviously exactly so how much are
we going to give up that kind of thing I
love some of the documentaries like what
was it kiss the ground it was really
fairly done too like no matter what your
political perspective is so yeah so we
wanted you know going back to food
sources fish we can't live without it
they're called essential fatty acids for
a reason so even if you don't want to
eat red meat all right let's at least be
a pescetarian yeah you gotta at least
eat fish or have a fish Source like for
your omega-3 fatty acids so that's a big
one so
um so I would say movement stress
reduction uh dietary stuff comes into
play but then address all those other
underpinnings like you know more micro
the the sort of micro micro problems
meaning like mold mold exposure toxicity
exactly and find a practitioner that's
more holistic and integrated that's
actually going to look under all those
stones yeah yeah
um what do you make like you talked
about long covet and stuff you know what
what do you make about uh people just
kind of dropping dropping to the ground
these days like you know the football
player that the football player that you
know the bills player that
um fell down on the field you look at
you see all these little videos of
people they're soccer players there's
people giving speeches there's people on
television it's basically like just
people doing what they're doing and you
just watch them like does that have to
do with I mean that seems very brain
oriented
yeah and and while they're actually this
one does get down a little bit more to
the cardiovascular level like one of the
top cardiologists I know is that we are
seeing more signs of myocardial he's
he's been in practice over 30 years he
said I'm seeing more signs of of
cardiovan like myocardial inflammation
in the last couple of years and I've
seen in 30 years of practice
okay now you know what is myocarditis
it's the inflammation of the cardiac
tissue yeah any items yeah well okay so
it's like we get into this whole thing I
what I try and do is have a pragmatic
conversation about vaccines all right
I'm sorry but there is risk involved in
vaccines that's just the nature of the
Beast and the problem is you can't you
know if you start to kind of address
vaccine risks you get censored like look
at what happened to Robert Malone he's
like guy and as soon as he is thank God
for Joe Rogan yeah and so you know here
you've got a guy that literally got shut
down all he was doing was trying to have
a pragmatic conversation saying look
there are risks involved that we don't
know everything that's going to happen
with the MRNA rookie all that stuff so
it and I'm seeing you know vaccine
injuries more than I ever have and most
of it is cardiovascular based so you
know endothelial inflammation and things
like that as well as this autonomia both
in covet and with the vaccine what that
is if you heard of conditions like pots
and things like that that happens in the
brain stem and that's where because we
talked about remember we just talked
about how the eyes and the balance
Center were directly with brother and
sister to your party like your veins
stuff and things like that yeah and that
area gets hit hard with a lot of these
things it even gets hit hard with mold
for example and so then what happens is
people have problems when they go to
stand up they don't have the right blood
pressure they don't have the right heart
rate and so you could imagine what's
happening to their system when it's
going all over the map because you only
have about four and a half liters of
blood and that brain stem that we're
talking about it's like a traffic cop
says okay Danica's standing up blood
Hugo here Danica's leaning forward blood
you go here that kind of thing okay
we're having a thought blood you go here
well if it's getting mixed signals or
like with a concussion or it's inflamed
and it's not it's you're functioning
properly like if you have inflammation
like let's say in your core it's not
going to go to your head as well because
it's essentially like a like a traffic
jam exactly and or another good analogy
it's like you have a the fight or flight
that you mentioned earlier that's the
sympathetics when the resting digesting
that's your break so you have gas fight
or flight resting digesting is your
parasympathetic when you're under attack
by something a virus or or you know
something an immune response that's
going after you know like a vaccine your
foot can get stuck on the gas pedal not
a good thing if you're going that brain
that's going 200 miles an hour you
better have a brake system to stop it
and if we can't get into that resting
digesting State our foot's stuck on the
gas pedal your blood your blood pressure
is in that same umbrella and so it can't
regulate properly for whatever it is
you're trying to do so that's when you
hear terms like this autonomy that's
kind of a general term of that part of
your brain stem being most of the time
it's stuck on the gas pedal you do have
times where your foot's stuck on the
brake and you can't get it off so that
you have but you have to be able to
address both of those so okay that's a
great explanation that makes a lot of
sense what about CTE I mean for all of
my sports fans out there and even
anybody that anything that you have to
wear a helmet is probably a concern but
there's a lot of people that played
Sports in school like but of course once
you do it for long enough
um what it what is CTE how what is it
and how is it treated okay that's uh so
CTE stands for chronic traumatic
encephalopathy and that's what that is
is basically taking all these mechanisms
that we're talking about like with brain
inflammation and protein misfolds like
the Golden Gate Bridge coming apart what
not and it's just over time that's what
happens and what happens if I punch
Bruce Banner and turn them into the hog
and I keep punching them guess what the
Hulk's gonna do I'm gonna stay the home
because you keep ticking me off and so
now the halt just keeps destroying the
city over a long period of time when you
look at the brain of a CTE patient it
looks very similar to that of an
Alzheimer's patient not wasting away way
that cortical atrophy where the the mass
those fractals that the brain is of all
those in foldings they waste away and
you get these big Open Spaces because
there's not as many neurons anymore and
then so then we go in you know and then
that we start to lose frontal control we
become more impulsive we become more
aggressive you know that's why you hear
a lot of the like the football players
and stuff or maybe a homicidal or
suicide like all these things that we
could normally inhibit they start to go
away so you want and it you know to your
point it can obviously football is a big
one but like even females the number one
cause of concussions is soccer you know
so yeah but you see it every we've all
been in car accidents we've all and it
doesn't even have to be head injury it
can be body impacts it can be cumulative
effect it doesn't have to be like the
one big one it's multiple impacts but
technically food and other things like
that that aren't healthy for you are
basically chemically concussing your
brain so it's it's like having multiple
NASCAR accidents can be analogous to
eating bad food all the time it's like
you're chemically concussing your brain
so they all can end up in that net
effect of brain atrophy like where it's
dying off we lose the connections we
can't you know the brain can't do what
it normally does the Leaky barriers then
open up the floodgates even more the
brain can't talk to the gut we're
getting malabsorption stuff you know
just you can see the brain controls
everything so when it starts to go down
your whole body goes into a spiral so
okay I just had a thought because
um so does first off the lasers are
going to do they regrow your brain do
they help it fill in for these little
gaps of atrophy do they do that that's
one of the coolest things yeah okay so I
totally forgot when I went and did a
brain scan with Dr Ayman yep
he was like so would I do the brain scan
then we're having something to eat
before we go in and do the interview
portion for his show
and uh I wanted some coffee finally
because I wasn't able to have coffee
before the test and so I you know we
were sitting down and they came in with
the folder with the results and I was
like oh my God I want some coffee I
don't even care if it's moldy I just
want some coffee and um and so he looked
at my chart he looked at the results
real quick and the Imaging and he was
like
um
yeah you can have coffee and then
afterwards he's like I mean basically it
was like you have a beautiful brain like
my brain looked almost like the ideal
brain which was just shocking to
everyone and as this is like when it
happened I was like wow I guess you know
my diet helps and working out but I
totally forgot that last year we did all
this laser stuff and we did it in a
concentrated amount of time so we got a
huge dose of it so it was you know 12
sessions over a month so like you know I
had I was in there a couple of times a
week and
um yeah I am sure that is probably why
my brain looked beautiful yeah and I
love what eamon's doing like the spec
studies because it's more functional
based right it's not just a static image
like an x-ray or an MRI it tells you how
the pathways are you know the the way
the fuels go into different parts of the
brain so yeah that's one of the cool
things is that there are studies that
that show that like the Holy Grail would
be to make new neurons like your neurons
don't replicate they don't go through
mitosis and so to get new neurons like
Stem Cell Activation with lasers new
neuronal neurogenesis and mitochondrial
like the PowerHouse with you can do it
with lasers the key is again like I have
my two of my first slides are low dose
it has to be like one study was one
joule per centimeter squared one was 0.8
so again it goes back to why I only use
archonia because they they can actually
it wasn't an erconia laser that in the
study but it was this you know very
similar parameters that that what
arconee does and so that is like the
holy grail and then the you then all you
got to do is is connect right you're
getting all these new uh new neurons but
the the growth factors that are
connecting the neurons together making
them talk there's there's terms like
bdnf nerve growth factor yeah well
lasers actually promote those protein
replications of bdnf will you please set
up my laser so I can laser my brain
every day here we go though I don't want
to like elect I don't want to like burn
a hole in the wall and even though I
know you can't because it's a cool laser
but one of the things that showed up in
the brain scan which is a perfect parlay
into this next part of the conversation
and I'm super interested to hear if
there's any studies or what the research
shows and I asked Dr Ayman about this
but one of the things he asked about
when he was looking at my brain in the
very center of my brain in the middle
was middle was lit up because what they
do is you're doing a a basic sort of
test where you're just basically hitting
a space bar if you see the X pop up
amongst all the letters like just don't
hit the space bar with the X so it's
very repetitive but it shows where your
brain is pumping firing essentially so
they inject a radio die into you to sort
of give you give them a snapshot of what
that is and then you go in the machine
the MRI machine and it scans but he said
this little spot right here he's like
tell me about uh psilocybin mushrooms
I was like well I just got back from
Burning Man
I actually was I think I just gotten
back from burning man
um so anyway what um are there any
studies on the uh benefits of plant
medicine and the brain and
neuroplasticity and new neurons or
um or perhaps bring growth just in any
way like uh maybe we're activating
dormant DNA like drop it on us there you
go you I love it this is so such a cool
area of research like just one Ayahuasca
of course which is what you had
mentioned early yeah Johns Hopkins just
don't they put 17 million dollars in the
soil Simon research in the recent years
and one of the reasons they're doing
that they're putting and so we're
getting really good clinical studies
done again on this stuff
um and to your point there are there are
they are showing like read everything
you can I know you have but Paul stamets
he's like the mushroom Guru right oh
yeah he was that Burning Man too I
wouldn't saw him talk I love it so yeah
without much mushrooms without fungi
like this planet we're toast we need
that they're like the great equalizer
for our planet to keep our ecosystems
alive things like that but it also it's
been shown to uh you know psilocybin and
mushroom derivatives like lion's mane
and would not have been shown to
increase nerve growth factors like those
proteins we were just talking about
change your microbiome in a positive the
good bacteria in you regulate your
immune responses just like the lasers
can do if your immune system is
overactive it'll calm it down if it's
under active it can help promote it so
yeah mushrooms are really good for that
but if you want to stabilize people that
are uh like bipolar for example for
example psilocybin is a way to do that
anxiety mushrooms can do that actually
technically all the classic psychedelics
like peyote and mescaline like Ayahuasca
like ibogain
psilocybin they all are really good for
stabilizing mood like anxiety addiction
for sure like if you're if I was going
to lose a kid to like an OP addiction
like narcotics or gotten like Fentanyl
and all the stuff that's going on right
now I would get them to an ibogaine
Clinic they don't have them in the
United States anymore but they have them
in Canada coasters yeah Iowa again it's
it's it's like the grandfather it's a
it's a African derivative that's the
ultimate reset button it takes all of
your egos
okay
eyebrows yeah it's a big one that's a
big one and I'm gonna tell you right now
Danica I tried it because I'm not one to
tell people to go do something if I
haven't tried it myself I I sat for a
day with iboga and it was the hardest 24
hours of my life it literally rings out
everything about your psyche your ego
that kind of stuff but you come out like
literally studies show and both you know
anecdotally as well too people come out
of these iboga clinics completely free
of opiate addiction and things like that
but in a smaller scale mushrooms like
psilocybin can do it
ayahuasca is like the master uh is the
mother ceremony it is the one that you
know it's when you think of the the best
analogy I give it's like a near-death
experience you hear about these stories
of people you know you know they've died
for some reason clinically and they're
getting drawn to the light and they're
being with God and things like that that
energy that love that is God's energy
kind of thing is you know that Universal
love and you I know we've both had
experiences where it's like that's you
if you're in that place it's the most
euphoric like words can't do it justice
on him no it's an it's an awareness it's
not even like you can't the words are
not don't there's too much essentially
there's just too much information it's
not you can't break it down into a
sentence you can't break it down into a
conversation it holds way more
information than that because it in fact
it you can feel it too it's very it's
hard to describe the way something feels
just like you can't like articulate or
Define love necessarily similar like you
can't it's too much information yeah
it's it's a pureness that's
Indescribable and my man ego would never
be able to do it justice so what what
they've done and where I'm getting to
with this is if you one of the things
that John's Hopkins is working is
they're giving cancer patients so high
dose and that I'm careful set and
setting right that's right right right
and these are scheduled you know when
you look at their you know the
substances are legal mostly in the
United States some some places are
starting to decriminalize them
thankfully but as a brain person they
are one of the most important things
that we're going to get to with
neuropsych stuff like depression like
anxiety because ssris and stuff I'm
sorry that's not doing anything exercise
will blow ssris yeah let alone diet
we'll blow ssris I mean I feel like you
hear uh you know the Peterson Family
Michaela and Jordan talk a lot about
that kind of stuff Michaela's been very
forthcoming with all of that and how
diet cured it all not ssris and the the
backlash of that it was so detrimental
yeah and and so the fear of dying like
because with cancer if it comes back
that's you know that's not a good sign
so what they do is they give people with
life life-threatening illnesses when
they give them a psilocybin like a
hero's dose as they talk about where you
you have that god-like experience if
that's what's waiting for us on the
other side guess what people lose their
fear of dying because I'm you know if
anything it'd be like oh well that's
what's going then you know I can't it's
it's almost inviting I can't wait I'm
talking about just on our physical
construct right yeah
but that is a big thing that I I mean
once I had my and here's another thing
I'll mention to get when I had my God
like Ayahuasca weekend it was my first
time sitting with Ayahuasca it was the
worst trip I could ever imagine but I'm
of the belief there's no such thing as a
bad trip so to speak because once I
finally let go of my ego and my default
mode Network and I truly in my deepest
sense at the time when I was on that
trip I said I ha I just want want to die
right now but I meant it in like the the
root of my core and every cell every DNA
of my body I felt that feeling and as
soon as I truly felt that
the lights I went into this space and I
got projected into the space of dark
energy and dark matter and I was with
God's energy and love and it was just
the most and it was literally like a
light switch turned off when I truly let
myself die yeah not just like oh I'm
gonna let go but when you just embody
letting go there's a big difference
between saying letting go and feeling
letting go to truly embody an emotion is
the magic of the universe Bingo and
that's why leading with your heart like
one of the ceremonies I sat with the
shaman came over and I was stuck my
energy was stuck and can I swear on your
yeah of course he goes he comes up to me
everyone's in ceremony there's like 14
of us on our mats and I was stuck and he
was working with my energy and moving
around he leaned Into Me Goes Trevor you
got an amazing brain is your
intelligence he goes quit using
it
the shaman put his hand on my heart and
as soon as I did that everything just
opened up and didn't you just post
something today on social media about
using leading with your heart and yeah
all the thoughts and stuff and so yeah
it's it's so to get to those places
sometimes those plant-based medicines
allow us to see things that we could
never do when we're stuck in our default
mode Network in those salience networks
and our Central Network system because
we start to perseverate and we sometimes
when that sled is going down the hill
and it's stuck in that Groove from that
Fresh coat of powder so that that sled
can go down a different route down that
hill and your life begins you know in a
whole different trajectory and that's
what the plant-based medicines do in
ways that to your point making new
Pathways and these Pathways they're
showing now in long-term studies like
the Johns Hopkins major depression study
not just a month later but they just did
a year follow-up that showed they were
still good A year later with depression
so it's a long-term neuroplasticity new
connections that kind of stuff and yes
the classic psychedelics can do all of
that wow yeah I mean I'm a big fan I
don't think there's I I mean I think you
can access other transcendental spaces
through meditation and various different
things and just breathing somewhere
where your breath work yeah of course
and some some other things but um but
there's nothing that's going to
um give you a more a bigger door to that
space than the psychedelics than the
plant medicines
um and but you do have to surrender that
is a hundred percent part of it people
that go into ceremony and they say they
didn't have anything happen I all I know
immediately that their guard is so far
up and they're not able to let go and
surrender because you have to surrender
to get the experience yeah and that's
very difficult when we have ego and
that's the whole thing is deconstructing
our ego and just as the Beatles song
like relax and flow Downstream right so
Lucy in the Sky there you go I wouldn't
go for the longest time that song was
about LSD yeah right
guy with diamonds yeah
they knew it was that the Beatles knew
it was up you're working with the brain
and neurology and
um Pathways and neuroplasticity and
epigenetics and these spaces that are
more Progressive in the scientific field
they're not
um you know this is we're working in
digital versus analog it feels like and
the people we're learning more and more
all the time and as you just said at the
beginning we now know another layer of
the brain that's got a cool name called
slime
um very very technical I'm sure it's uh
I'm sure it stands for something
um but what is it what is it that's
building our reality I'm curious what
your thoughts your opinion or perhaps
what you know what research has shown
that builds this reality
um because the brain and and what the
role of the brain is like what is the
brain what is its function and what is
building this reality
to dovetail off the Psychedelic side of
things if you look at you know you hear
these terms like we only use x percent
of our brain and things like that and
that's you know in our in our current
form as it is and our constructs our
man-made limitations or or you know
self-limitations if you will
um we only get to appreciate certain
elements but if you think of it as
universal intelligence like there's an
energy out there and again this gets
into those definition things is it God
you know everyone's definition of God is
you know different that kind of thing
that energy that that is out there and
they're starting to study in more like
the CERN super collider you know the
news and God Particle all that stuff but
as we look into that that's one of the
things that plant-based medicine does it
allows us to peer over our own veil of
ego in our own limitations and look into
that bigger picture and so there's some
thought that what you know we're just
we're getting that Universal waveform
that we're all in to interconnected and
that our Consciousness just intersects
those waves because you know everything
the quantum models everything that's
exactly what it is yeah everything's a
wave right and it's when our con when we
look at a table and touch it's our
Consciousness that intersects those
waves and turns it into you know how we
describe it and how because non-locality
has been proven to like the table's not
really here until observed that's it
that's proven now and that's one of the
beautiful things about mescaline and
peyote is that it allowed me I I felt
like I literally was one with the world
the amount I was actually being buried
alive out in the desert and the beauty
of it I had no fear I had no it was like
this is the coolest thing I was
connected to the Mount like all these
inanimate objects like mountains and
everything was becoming one and that's
what you know that's part of those
Vision quests those trips is just to
appreciate that we're all connected our
vibration you know you talked about
quantum entanglement we will go two
different directions and yet still have
the exact same properties you know going
either way and that kind of thing but
then you look at
um how Consciousness when we look at get
it for more of a reductionist model so
I'm we've been talking a lot about
expanding outside you know in that
direction but as we start to look inside
of the human body and how we're made up
of fractals our universe is fractals our
the worldliness trees ferns I I when I
message you the other day I said you
know my spirit animal is what Romanesco
broccoli it's that fractal pattern and
one of those beautiful vegetable in the
world right isn't it and so one thing I
know when I'm sitting in in ceremony is
that when I start seeing those fractal
patterns a lot of people are cool with
that it's like this cool visual
Kaleidoscope right that's actually
almost like a Gateway that tells me oh
I'm about to have a big lesson coming my
way and once you get through those
fractal patterns then you open up to the
other side and she gives you know these
medicines give different teachings each
time like I sat with Ayahuasca now about
14 times I've had a different experience
completely every time because it's such
a great saying it doesn't give you what
you want to gives you what you need
Bingo and you just literally took the
words right on my own so so that is one
Element but I'm realizing as I look back
at the the so we started with the the
Penrose uh you know hammeroff model and
and we're this is a beautiful segue into
it because I'm realizing if that theory
is correct and we look at the reduction
going inside ourselves because we are
God we are you know that kind of thing
within our own embodiment if you look at
it from trying to do the scientific
model and this is where it gets tough
this is where I love Terence McKenna's
quote he goes how are you going to learn
how a clock works by Smashing it to
Pieces so you can study the different
pieces
you know what what you know all right
I'm paraphrasing him but it was
something yeah yeah that's where the
scientific model becomes very difficult
because the more we pull stuff apart and
break it apart to look at it the harder
it is to really see how it works as a
whole so that's like when those UFO
crafts crashed and Roswell and they had
to put it back together they weren't
sure how to do it they've been working
on it for decades what a great example
what a great analogy and and well maybe
we'll get you have time to get into that
crossbeam in Egypt you know looking at
the the UFO yeah but I wore my Cartouche
today just for good luck oh I love it I
had a bunch of those brought back my
name on the back I didn't I didn't even
think I have I did a wrist one I love
that though those are so pretty
um yeah and and so with the as we go
into the neurons or into our body it's
fractals everywhere the patterning it's
that if anyone's not familiar with
fractals it's the most beautiful visual
it's it's the mathematical equation
that's never ending
um and and when it's represented in a
physical actually you know what I did
was I think I downloaded a picture
actually I'll pull it up later but if
you look if people want to Google
mandelbrot set and you can see those
fractal patterns and you can actually
just stare at it well fractal patterns
have a range of one to two so they and
what Mother Nature has done is its
fractal ratio is typically 1.3 to 1.5
and that has to do with the complexity
of those fractals so you know a really
good example for for a certain
demographic would be like a Jackson
Pollock painting yeah what what they
have found out was his paintings he was
actually painting in fractal ratios
yes and so when he first started
painting his ratio was very simple was
it just a 1.0 ratio but by the time his
career ended or he stopped painting it
was 1.7 he didn't know he was doing that
on purpose or was that that was just
that was just he he is just part of the
damn pattern exactly we are pattern
making machines like oh my God exactly
and so mother nature is a pattern making
machine look at look at your
cardiovascular system
tree roots that's right that's your
blood vessels in your heart look at that
fractal pattern it looks like it's
beautiful I was uh on mushrooms one time
and I watched my veins sprouting
crystals and that was essentially what
it was doing it was constantly like
sprouting and it's growing and crystals
and it was like I was like wow that's
amazing and my body said
I love you so much I'm doing this for
you all the time oh my God is that
beautiful
those lessons that you get those
epiphanies that kind of stuff and and
you know with the the like mother nature
in that 1.3 to 1.5 if you have a patient
trying like the studies show if you look
at fractal patterns in that range you'll
have a 60 reduction in stress
what oh my God you're reorganizing your
brain yeah so we're fractal beings oh my
God you know in Egypt they said that
some of the
um like the RAM and different faces they
actually activated based on their
geometry your brain in certain ways
exactly and the sacred the sacred
geometry is what that's all about right
and so that was like you know just being
out in nature if you want if you're a
patient in a hospital bed get to a
window that you asked outside your
healing capacity is going to go up
greatly just by seeing fractal patterns
we're using it now even like look at Ben
Weiss's uh Ted Talk on fractals he's
kind of like one of Mabel brought's
disciples they're using those mandelbrot
sets in learning disability in cognitive
behavioral stuff things like that just
based on Staring at a fractal pattern
Activation so then you look at it inside
your body your lung feels like the
bronchial tree your capillary your blood
vessel bed your brain all those folds on
top of each other are fractal patterns
your neurons all the dendrites that
connect to each other it's all fractal
patterns and it looks exactly like and I
did download one more and I did this
small because if you look yeah oh yeah
neurons one's a neuron one's the
universe yeah exactly of course you
can't tell the difference because
they're a fractal because no matter how
much you zoom in or how much you zoom
out it's the same pattern exactly so now
we go keep going into the neuron now
we're back to the microtubule that we
started with and the quantum
Consciousness model of Penrose and
hamara is to say that with to have a
super computer that like if you do
Quantum Computing it's non-binary right
it's not one and zero it's somewhere in
between and it can be in any
configuration at any time so to be able
to have this type of activity you have
to have fractal patterns that the
electrons are bouncing around in and
that's what they are saying is the
theory of quantum Consciousness is the
fractal pattern in that microtubule so
in a in a you know when you look at it
from a reductionist standpoint it's not
because it's actually opening up into
that realm of those fractal patterns in
our brains that are tapping into the
universal connectiveness of fractal
patterns that are never ending
have you heard of nasimharamine I have
yeah he was he said one at one point
that we are our own black hole
and that when I saw a video by this girl
named Sarah alcaldy that I interviewed
she goes by The Alchemist on Instagram
she's fascinating
um she has great videos on YouTube as
well um but she had just posted
something the other day talking about
basically kind of the universe within
you kind of a theory but far more
scientific or like deeper than that and
my reply to her was does this account
for quantum entanglement because I think
about quantum entanglement you think
about it's the equal and opposite
reaction instantaneously no matter how
far apart the part the particles are so
the only thing that kind of like I don't
know we actually have the hardware to
even
ask the right question or complete or
understand I'm not sure we have the I
don't think we have the hardware but
maybe or maybe we are continuing to grow
into that Hardware but my question was
does this explain something to do with
quantum entanglement because if it's if
it's equal and opposite and
instantaneous there seems like there has
to be some kind of black hole loophole
some kind of loop that happens within
all of us that is mimicking in in the
rest of the universe and So I responded
with that and she said you've just
actually hit on exactly what my next
video is about because yes you're on to
something and I was like oh my God
that's well said I love it and another
interesting side note on on that element
is with the fractals is that
um with the the the the most recent
studies that are being done there's like
a serpinski triangle I don't know if
you've read about any of that at all but
it's like some of the top Quantum
researchers are using some of these
they're trying to create a model that
that they could you know use as the
model for Quantum you know quantum
mechanics and what they're doing guess
what they're doing to activate this this
triangle it's the fractal model that
they're using is that they put a photon
of light
into the tip of it and guess what
happens
it exponentially communicates with the
entire fractal pattern
so this gets into why light therapies
we're we're light driven beings if
without the sun we're not here without
light energy without that kind of
wavelength and we're not here we don't
exist plants don't exist we're toast
yeah so you think about mycelium even
when you think about the fungi and the
fungi you know uh Universe essentially
in the soil the mycelium is
communicating it's an in it's a system
of communication just like your brain or
just like the universe it's fractal
exactly and so so one of the neat ideas
then that that takes you know where my
mind goes with the laser neurology stuff
is that we're just tapping into
activating these fractal patterns yeah
based on just using and I again I'm
grossly overstating this but that
serpinsky triangle method that's
actually getting that light Photon
energy into the body it doesn't have to
be a high amount it doesn't that's what
the research shows as well just getting
that low dose and goes and so I love
that and I think one way to get to those
answers too and that's why a lot of the
high thinkers you know the Steve Jobs
one that there's a lot of known activity
with psilocybin and LSD and stuff in
Silicon Valley and some of them Moscow
is the Burning Man all the time yeah
well and I love it so to get to these
answers sometimes you got to get out of
it's like Einstein's you know you can't
be in the same mindset of what created
those problems you have to get above it
well how do we do that the plant-based
medicine will help facilitate that so we
can get into areas of Consciousness or
whatever however we wanted to find it
where we can come up with different
epiphanies and solutions and answers
that we can't get in this current
embodiment yeah what did you learn when
you went to Egypt do you feel like any
puzzle pieces came together or or or a
really important question of rose from
the experience was that your first time
to Egypt that was my first time yeah and
so you went last year and and I went the
year before and um you know for me I
definitely came away with like we don't
get it but I'm curious what your
experience was like and how that plays
into Consciousness
fractals geometry
uh and reality yeah yeah for them to
have the answers to like let's just put
the placement of the Great Pyramid
in Giza you know it's perfect it's
perfectly aligned 30 degrees latitude
perfectly north north south east west
but when you look at even the parameters
of it it's in the ratios associated with
the entire universe the Earth's radius
diameter and whatnot is built into the
size of the pyramid our distance time
you know the time mechanism is built
into the size of the pyramids the ratio
of you know when you hear of like terms
like one to forty three thousand two
hundred like what the Earth's
circumference in diameter Randall
Carlson does an amazing job with the
sacred geometry stuff he's brilliant
with that stuff along with Graham
Hancock Robert Edward Grant too I've
interviewed him and I've become friends
with him and he is all up in the set in
the geometry especially of Egypt and
then even the alignment you know you
look at William Hancock's worth and
maybe I won't go too deep down that
because you could ever you know he's
been so like his new Netflix special
part it's phenomenal I recommend
everyone watch it but even the alignment
you know one of the the things that that
I had happened that was tied into Egypt
there was a huge Epiphany because I
didn't know this when I had my my first
when I was projected into like when I
was with God in heaven and all this
stuff is that I was in the areas of like
um you know the stars and and the
alignment what what's the theory is is
that the pyramid when you look at the
the placement of the king and the king
the king and queen's tombs or yeah the
chambers yeah the chamber sorry that
when you go up into that area they talk
about those shafts and you know the
classic Egypt tall as well it's just
ventilation shaft no what the the
Egyptians believe was that they were
trying to project their souls to Orion's
Belt Osiris Isis you know before so that
their souls could be in the Heavens For
Eternity and the alignment of the queen
shaft and the King shaft are exactly
where they need to be to project that
and that was based on the procession of
you know when you look at that the time
of their uh alignment and when it was
developed there's perfect alignment with
with Orion's Belt like the three
pyramids in the way they are the
direction the way the Sphinx is looking
all that stuff was back in wheels so and
I you know I was one of my experiences
with the medicine was I was in that
place and I didn't even know it at the
time but then when I went to Egypt and
realized that's where they were trying
to project to but it was Ayahuasca that
allowed me to get there so then you see
all throughout the hieroglyphics and not
that there is evidence of them doing
psychedelics plant-based stuff you'll
see on some of the you know the holding
the pipe and the they're smoking things
like that you know the belief is that
they're actually you know using that for
higher brain function and getting to
levels of conscious awareness or in you
know Endeavors that you you couldn't in
the physical form let alone for eternity
kind of things so they have their
gateways that you saw there and you know
their their false doors and things like
that
um what was the one Temple the Newt
Chapel ceiling it was actually a Gateway
it was like this enclosed building
that's a gateway to project to the
Astros so a lot of the astrology
critical stuff that's out there was tied
into Egypt but I know the one you and I
are dying to talk about is that is that
Cross Beam that's at um the Temple of
surdy and uh abados oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh of course with the Flower of
Life yeah well and then there's the uh
when you look at the
um the the progression there's a
submarine there's a UFO oh yeah of
course yeah that one there's a
helicopter there's right the hieroglyphs
that show that that you show literally
like it's a helicopter it's a boat it's
a boat a submarine a UFO like come on
and so they try and pawn it off with
these theories like well it was actually
uh when you when you try and superimpose
30 over Ramses then that's actually when
you put their names together in
hieroglyphics you get this you know that
was one of the theories I'm like oh so
all of a sudden those make uh and but
even if that were the case because a lot
of times they'll superimpose as another
ruler takes over they change the
hieroglyphics so like I'm not dismissing
that but to use that theory as what
explains there's a UFO yeah uh summary
like I'm sorry that that doesn't jive
with me so you know I I challenge
everyone to Google that and look at that
Cross Beam and make your own judgment
because it has been confirmed or
affirmed that
um that is actually done in times where
these you know some reasons didn't exist
exactly so that was a really big
eye-opening I stood there and stared at
that for I don't know how long just
trying to to absorb that and see because
then it brings in the question of okay
we we know the government's just open up
what 400 documents of classified
information of UFO sightings and things
like that so we know that some of them
has been dismissed as actually
identified as like a drone or something
like that but there's a lot of them
they're going yep dude we went to Mars
with a drone why do people think it's so
freaking outside the box that something
visits us like literally we are on
another planet
exactly so to think that we're the only
ones within 10 intelligent life form and
whatnot it exists I think that's a
little bit of a a stretch especially
even as you know the biggest doubters as
as we start to get more and more you
know proof If you will or evidence that
that we're seeing alien like like UFOs
and things like that and and let alone
what you see in the in the common
denominators of people that have been
you know uh you know when you talk about
abductions or different things like that
whatever the the experience is there has
to be more than what we allow for based
and again it's a comfort thing I get
there's a safety zone nobody wants to
think that you know like the movies like
Independence Day like something's going
to come down yeah that's exactly how
it's gonna go yeah exactly you know it's
like if you know if the if if it's all
about that Universal intelligence and
its love is the universal language
coming from here then yeah let's just
tap into that let's all stay connected
let's all be brother and sister let's
all you know do this together and quit
being so divisive and and that's we're
burning man and things like that that's
do such a good job I think everyone a
burning man 2023. I definitely would
would invite that I've been me I've done
like I know you've got some good outfits
I know that I know that I do have a few
of those so I will pick you up on that
well Burning Man 2023 I'll put it on my
radar here so uh man I imagine that you
know it's nothing like Independence Day
it's if there was an extraterrestrial
entity that came through I imagine it to
be like how you talked about
um being in a different space with plant
medicine and being like in the soil and
part of the earth you know you felt
totally at peace and love I imagine that
there are so many benevolent entities
and that their their presence they would
be able to affect me on on a level of
Consciousness that would make me at
peace and at ease so when I walk outside
at night to walk the dogs because I'd
just get a little scared of coyotes jump
in the wall when I go outside with them
at night I imagine I'm like okay I look
up every night and I'm like show me some
see I want to see I'm like come I'm like
wait no I'm scared of no no and I
run inside like I'm not sure I'm ready
but maybe when I actually fully
surrender and I am embodying ready then
they will show up
um so I imagine that maybe they're there
the whole time but it takes something
like the higher vibration level of being
with plant-based medicine that actually
allows us
yes so what is what is like the future
of Consciousness like maybe let's not
even I don't wanna I don't want to get
to like sciency
I want to keep it in the realm of
philosophy
spirituality
uh where what is the future of
Consciousness as we transcend to what we
could maybe say like next level
I think
going back without getting too
scientific
oh my goodness Danica that is a that is
the question Beyond questions like I'd
almost have to be in an altered state
with the planet stuff to actually do
that answer Justice because all right
reach into your drawer I'll go into mine
okay
now just for those watching I'm not in
the United States right now I'm outside
of the country as I reach into my oh no
I'm just kidding yeah yeah wink wink no
it's yeah so oh my goodness well what is
your thought on that because I I I okay
all right all right I'll give you some
I'll give you some moments I imagine
that the the the next state the next
level of Consciousness
um is where uh the most prevalent
information that we use to navigate in
our day is the orientation to our
emotional body and intuition we call it
intuition because this is the best word
we have for it it doesn't sound very
scientific except there's information
from the field coming to us and giving
it to our body and so since we are
having such a hard time deciphering like
what's and what's not like
what's propaganda what's a lie in the
media like we don't know and I think
that it's calling us to go Inward and
use our own biological system
neurofeedback biological medical
feedback to navigate the world from a
new plane of existence from with a with
a A different kind of awareness and I
think that then when we look one step
further or one step over I think that
also Consciousness will Elevate when as
you say come together I think when
masculine and feminine energy within
each and every one of us is balanced and
United in a pure healthy productive way
respectful way I think that when we go
into relationship with anyone else
whether it be a partner a friend family
whatever that is we now have a different
relationship with the with the people
around us because we are no longer
triggered we are no longer in our ego we
are merely honoring ourselves and the
other for where they shine and in those
two with those two things I don't think
there's any way that we don't transcend
the reality that we live in today
you know that's that's beautifully
standard but okay that's you you got a
whole book going right there I love that
that was I I don't even know how to
follow up on that but I I love how you
said that because I do think that that
when we can deconstruct our own Egos and
get to that place of pureness and and
that inner peace that we don't have to
prove anything to anyone that we're not
against each other that we're together
anything that gets us to that place is
going to allow uh you know not just our
world but the entire you know Universal
intelligence in the community you know
that we connect into we can open up and
into that and to do that that's one of
the reasons I love the again not to
perseverate on it but the plant-based
medicines are kind of the one of the
main opportunities that we have to break
through that that and deconstruct
ourselves to get to that place so I I
love it I think as it becomes more
mainstream which I hate that term but
it's like more accepted would maybe be a
better way of doing that not this taboo
you know the war on drugs and and that
kind of thing yeah I don't want people
in trouble out there I don't want
fentanyl I don't want overdose I don't
want I don't even want marijuana being
too manipulated to have a high THC
content that can be inflammatory or done
too early to create psychotic break you
know there's there's always risks
involved and things like that but
relative to what we're doing in medicine
and Healthcare you know it's the safety
net and the safe place that plant-based
stuff can can do when it's controlled
and it's in the right environment in the
right setting it it allows us to get the
places to what you just so eloquently
stated in a way that nothing else can so
I do think that's a big way of the
future I do think the the
um the energy of lasers and things the
big way of the future because we got to
get away from this chemical model
anytime man attaches something to
something so we can patent it and sell
it we tend to get in trouble with it it
tends to cause like look at aspirin you
know Willow barn now we put we attach
something to it so that we can sell it
and it starts ripping holes in our
stomach comics and you know that kind of
stuff so so what let Mother Nature do
its thing let energy of different
waveforms do its thing and that's when
you put those two together I think
there's going to be some magic in the
future yeah oh man
that was fun that was fun I knew we were
gonna go down some fun rabbit holes but
oh man well you
know we're doing it while recording but
it's fun and you know we connected on a
lot of those levels very early on and I
think that um I it was it's refreshing
to
um to work with a Doctor Who's as
accomplished and intelligent as you are
uh with
um mature discernment for uh all of the
uh options and modalities out there that
exist so truly I I hope I I hope that in
the future every doctor orients
themselves the way that you do and it
was so much fun to work with you and um
I'll see you soon so figure out these
lasers all right Danica thank you I'm
very humble has truly been an honor to
be with you and I love keep doing what
you're doing get that prop yo they get
the message out there allow people to be
free thinkers and keep your health stuff
that you're doing I can't thank you
enough for being you know such a great
Ambassador for everything that you have
been sharing you know and everything
that you stand behind so I hope to do it
again and we'll see you soon well you
know I mean I after my imp my explant
surgery I was in your office a couple of
days later like and you were you put
lasers on me to start healing and
everything so you're all part of the
process so thank you yeah and I look
forward we'll get you going in full
speed on your erconia laser all your
homework stuff you'll be lazing your
brain every day like I do so well I will
all right thanks Trevor thanks Danica
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button